good morning mr. president
pietatis ladies and gentlemen thank you
very much for this opportunity to share
my thoughts today with you and to listen
to your views it is just a few weeks ago
6-8 weeks ago that have been at the
World Economic Forum in Davos and I had
a meeting with the International
Business Council and someone asked me
the very right question
he said do we want Europe to be a global
player or playground for others and this
is the big question indeed it's as
simple as that
and I have no doubt about the answer I'm
absolutely confident that Europe will
continue to be a global player in the
world of tomorrow and I'm confident
because I know what European business
are capable of we are the continent of
innovators with a continent of pioneers
of entrepreneurs we are continent of
family companies that have resisted all
crisis's and that have reinvented
century-old productions we're leaders in
a huge number of sectors from the
automotive to clean energy from
chemicals to satellite but we also know
that industry is changing faster than
ever before and we have to define a new
industrial way for Europe in this
rapidly changing world
I see basically three main drivers of
this change the first one is of course
you know it all technology it's about
big data
it's about artificial intelligence
they're completely reshaping the way we
do things and this is not about just
about self-driving cars you know it's
way more it's a revolution that is
touching all sectors of our economy from
farmer to fashion from big factories to
every small family enterprise
it is indeed all about data data is the
fuel of our economy artificial
intelligence will soon help companies
for example to reduce their energy bills
by smartly allocation allocating the
energy over day and night in the
companies it will provide a better
consumer and customer service it will
transform our design and production
processes all this you know it better
than me is already happening and many of
see you see it in your daily business
and your daily work the challenge for
Europe is not just to adapt to these
changes the challenges that we want to
shape our own digital future and I'm
confident that we are able to do that
the second main driver you had it in the
film too is the sorry state of our
environment 2050 that is the year Europe
aims to become carbon neutral climate
neutral and it's no longer impossibly
distant if I think of my children they
will be a little younger than I am now
in 2050 a little bit younger and I
haven't you all have a glimpse of the
possible environment they will likely
experience and it's a sobering glimpse
if we don't change dramatically and
honestly I feel a profound sadness that
they might be dealing with severe
problems of our making
and you know these problems just to name
a few
it's the reduced biodiversity we're
using 1 million of species it's the
rising sea levels we know today already
what Islands will disappear and what
cities it's already affect it is the
increasing desert if ocation which
causes a huge amount of security
problems and conflict potential science
is clear human caused climate disruption
is one of the best studied phenomenons
in this world and the majority has
understood this and your film showed it
but some are still deploying the notion
that you can downplay climate change and
want to continue with business as usual
well I think this is not only
unacceptable with regard to our children
and their right to live in harmony of
innate and with nature as we have it but
it would also be a huge missed economic
opportunity businesses all across Europe
demonstrate that a different growth
model is possible a growth model that
creates jobs and economic value why are
we while respecting our environment and
be it from the small enterprises that
are renouncing single-use plastic or the
big steel industries that have launched
a transition towards fossil free steel
some of you have started to develop
their own sectoral Green Deal the steel
sector is already doing that others like
the chemical sectors on the point of
joining all this is great news it's
necessary great news for the environment
but also for Europe's
competitiveness at the end of last year
44 of Europe's largest investors
representing six trillion of assets
asked us the European Union the European
Commission to urgently pass a climate
law why that they want reliability they
want clarity they want us to be
dedicated to go towards that goal and
rightly so and indeed as you've said
President got us yesterday we have made
our proposal for the first-ever European
climate law it will help you plan your
long term investment it will provide a
clear sense of direction all across our
union I see the climate transition as a
huge opportunity for the European
economy and for the European business we
can develop and deploy clean
technologies that the whole world will
want to adopt to cut pollution and to
enhance productivity we can set new
standards and we can become the
exporters of knowledge driven clean
technologies we can be a world leader
also taking the most ethical choices we
have the first advantage of the first
mover's so we are ahead of other
continents of other sectors which is not
in every case the reality of the
European business and this is why I
think of the European Green Deal as our
new growth strategy a strategy for
growth that is not constrained by fossil
fuel and that is but not constrained by
the constant need for more resources but
rather a strategy for growth that offers
maximum added value
with renewable resources while gaining
the trust of our society because people
have a gut feeling on what is going on
and they want a different approach to
growth the third driver of change for
our industry is geopolitics and the
growing pressures from international
competitors you know at all it's
straight disputes it's the return of
protectionism and yes the global
competition is fierce but European
businesses be they large or be they
small have the quality and the capacity
for innovation and to thrive in this
difficult environment through years many
of you have become stronger thanks to
the single market and you have made the
jump to the global markets to become
world leaders in your sectors European
companies have prospered thanks to our
unique set of free trade agreements and
thanks to a global trade system that is
based on rules we have many many success
stories to be proud of from Telecom to
railways from aircrafts to agriculture
but indeed we also have to ensure that
our industry and their workers are
competing in a fair environment not only
at home but also abroad in these years
with witnessed unilateral and arbitrary
action against our industries there is
hostility against the WTO and against
the idea of a level playing field for
companies all over the world so the
challenge we face is to safeguard this
level playing field for European
industries internally
and externally you must be able to
innovate and compete in fairness and
because this determines European
prosperity now and in the future and in
this context allow me indeed to make a
few remarks about our relationship with
the United States because you mentioned
it president get us I just want to
emphasize first of all with all the
disputes we do have and all the issues
we do have with the United States and
the White House at the moment being I'm
a strong believer in the transatlantic
friendship and the solid foundation we
have for this transatlantic friendship
there zillions of contacts with our
American friends business contacts
personal friendships our researchers
scientists culturally so we should
always keep that in mind when tackling
with the obvious problems that are out
there without any question I had a good
meeting with President Trump in Davos
and I believed that there might be a
momentum towards improving our relations
on a positive footing of course and this
is for you to know I am absolutely aware
that any deal that might be worked out
needs to be balanced and compliant with
WTO rules and it has to be compliant
with the existing European Union mandate
as you mentioned at President Carter's
so back to the initial question will
Europe be a global player or will it be
a playground for others well after the
first 100 days in office let me tell you
that I have seen a resolute Europe I
have seen a Europe from the business
sector and from the youth movements and
from societies civil societies that is
clearly demanding for ambitious goals
from vicious policies
and we have set out goals in our
clearest possible way we want climate
neutrality we want digital leadership we
will not just adapt to the change we
will shape it with our own capacity of
innovation and by doing so make Europe
more competitive in the world a
continent that has a vision a continent
that has foresight a continent that has
resolution a continent that takes
control of its own future and a
continent that masters its own destiny
and it is with this in mind that we have
presented the European Green Deal and
our digital strategy and next week
indeed we will in introduce our industry
strategy and our SME strategy and let me
take five thoughts out of those two to
discuss briefly with you first of all
and you're absolutely right president
guitar's we need to invest in Europe's
most unique asset and that is our single
market with its size it can offer scale
efficiencies and purchasing power to
match the US and China we should not
underestimate that but indeed our single
market has to catch up with the changing
industry all companies today are
becoming and have to become digital so
the challenge for us is to truly digital
eyes now the single market truly digital
eyes it and our challenge is to make it
work better for all these businesses so
for example we have to invest in a new
network of digital innovation hubs all
across Europe or we want to set up
European data spaces and European
supercomputers I'm a big believer that
we have a huge opportunity with these
European data spaces we've started it
already for the researchers that is you
have a data space where you do not only
store your own data but it enables you
to get access to other researchers data
at the same time and the same has to go
for the business sector the same
actually has to go for governments they
have an enormous amount of data that are
being never ever used 85% of all our
data we collect are never used or
underused so we we should share them
because there's a huge amount of
innovation in it entrepreneurship missed
opportunities and if we have these
European data spaces there's access to
it another example medical researchers
are able right now to use the potential
of the supercomputers in Barcelona on
Bologna to identify a cure to the corona
virus so in other word thanks to
European funds we're funding the next
generation of supercomputers for our
businesses for our researches second
topic we must get away from the old
model where we take resources from the
environment put it in a product just to
turn them then into waste our our
current linear production methods create
huge quantities of greenhouse gas
emissions if you just think of the
mining of raw materials the import a
transformation into a product the
landfill of waste we throw away all this
creates an immense amount of carbon
dioxide and waste if we want climate
neutrality and there are good reasons
for it it's an existential need we
definitely need to move on to the so
called circular models of production
you know the examples of the reuse for
example the cost of manufacturing mobile
phones
could be reduced by 50% per device
if industry made phones easier to take
apart if we improved in reverse cycles
and if we offered incentives to return
them or the other example you know it
high-end washing machines
very normal they would be accessible for
house households not by selling them to
them but by leasing machine loads what
is the difference if you sell the
machine there is a certain incentive to
be aware of the fact that at a certain
time it breaks and you exchange it for
the next one if you sell the Machine
load so you just leave the machine to
the household the incentives are
completely different so the incentive
for the manufacturer is that you develop
a washing machine that is long lasting
as long as possible so that you can sell
more a more way more machine loads to
the household you sell the service you
don't sell the product anymore and
there's a huge incentive to recycle the
product and not to throw it away there
is an environmental reason to choose the
circular economy without any question
but I think there's also a huge economic
one because Europe realized massively on
the import of raw material from abroad
we import half of all our resources we
consume half of it we input this is
expensive you know it better than me it
exposes companies to price fluctuations
and it makes us dependent on others for
a number of critical raw materials look
at what is happening now with
coronavirus it just takes us 2 to 3
weeks and we know all here what it does
to our supply chains so the circular
economy is not
a measure of sustainability it's also a
matter of sustainability without any
question but also a matter of
competitiveness and a matter of serenity
third topic Europe needs an industry
that reminds competitive on the global
stage while going green and digital
European Union's competition law has
served Europe well without any question
by contributing to a level playing field
and we all know being competitive abroad
requires competition at home but in a
fast changing world not least with
Europe embarking on its major twin
transitions our competition rules will
be revised to ensure they remain fit for
today's world for example if we want to
incentivize fossil flue free productions
we cannot accept but at the same time
carbon heavy products re imported from
abroad this is neither sustainable No is
it fear to our industry therefore we are
committed to developing a carbon border
adjustment mechanism yesterday I have
launched our impact assessment for that
all relevant sectors will be consulted
in the most transparent and inclusive
manner and there's another factor if we
want a level playing field in our single
market we must also react to subsidies
that distort competition not only when
it comes to Member States but also when
we look at our trading partners from
other regions of this world and this is
why we want an instrument on foreign
subsidies we want to remain open for
foreign investors without any questions
but there has to be a certain level of
reciprocity we need this reciprocity the
same rights foreign firms enjoy and our
borders within our borders European
firms
also enjoy abroad I think this is a
matter of fairness and for that reason I
call on Member States and the European
Parliament to finalize now the
instrument the international procurement
instrument that we need for that we are
an open economy without any question
we're thriving in a global economy but
this openness should not be taken for
granted if we are faced with unfairness
we are ready to address that the fourth
point Europe must master the key
technologies of tomorrow if we build our
technological sovereignity we will also
create new businesses opportu business
opportunities for our companies there's
for example the story of our battery
alliance that makes a very good example
and right in front of me it's kind of
the pattern of our battery exile
alliance it's Maris F ker which the
vice-president batteries will be
strategic in a cleaner and more digital
environment but Europe still relies
massively on batteries that are entirely
or proudly made abroad and this is why
we decided to join forces with member
states and the private sector and so the
European battery Alliance was born it is
thanks to it that the most innovative
long-lasting and clean batteries for
electric cars will soon be made in
Europe and the same model can be applied
in other strategic sectors just think of
hydrogen to produce clean steel think of
5g and 6g networks think of AI driven
Diagnostics in the medical sector or the
robots for healthcare think of the
industrial Internet of Things but also
of course of cybersecurity and there are
many many other examples these
technologies will be crucial for
prosperity and security in the future so
we must guarantee our autonomy all along
these value chains that are necessary to
produce these topics and in a more
competitive world this is not only an
investment in our competitiveness but
it's also an investment in our own
sovereignty and speaking of investment
this is the fifth point massive
investment will be needed both public
and private we want you to invest but we
want to invest with you also and we want
to make it easier for you to invest I'm
talking about investment and research
I'm talking about investment in new
technologies but also about investment
in the deployment and the take up of
these technologies by companies of all
sizes talking about the European Green
Deal it's not so much in investing and
basic R&D because this takes 20 30 40
years till its market feasible the
technologies are out there already we
have them but they are not deployable at
the moment being they are not making
market feasible so this is the point
where we have to step in and help and
invest and nurture or for example take
hydrogen hydrogen will become key for
the industrial sectors we had it several
times now sighted today but the market
is not yet there to sustain its
deployment and development in ready
solutions there was a need to stimulate
investment across different sectors and
industries and for this reason we
created the industry with the industry a
public-private partnership on hydrogen
and today Europe is one of the global
leaders on hydrogen stations and fuel
cell buses so we are now ready to expand
this very positive model of
innovation with a new generation of
impact driven public-private partnership
supported by the European budget I think
this is a combination we do need we want
to stimulate investment and we want
innovation all across the value change
chain we want to involve industries be
they large or be they small we want to
create lead markets for new technologies
and for that if these are our goals if
we aim at that we want to make life
easier for investors the European
classification for sustainable
investment that's the first step to take
we will also strengthen the rules on
disclosure on environmental information
by companies we will define high quality
standards on green bonds yes I know this
is a lot but it's necessary and we do
all this so that investors can identify
what investment is sustainable and what
investment is not because your
investment decisions of today are vital
to make the two twin transitions the
digital one and the green one happen and
I fully agree with you president guitars
as you said that a stable and a
predictable policy environment stable
and predictable for you is key to foster
investment ladies and gentlemen
Europe has always been the home of
Industry and small and medium businesses
for century it has been an industry
pioneer for innovation and for centuries
it has helped improve the way people
around the world produce consume and do
business Europe's business has powered
our economy it has provided stable
living conditions for many and your film
showed it impressively I mean this is
always the goal why we do all this and
it has created a social hub around with
our community
that is stable that is reliable and this
is the European way throughout its long
history industry has proven its ability
to lead the change yes it has been
difficult sometimes yes the road has
been bumpy but in the very end we have
been able to lead change and it must do
the same now as Europe's markets embark
on the twin transition on the
digitalization and the European Green
Deal this is what will truly make a
difference between success and failure
it will make the difference and our
ability to join forces between public
and private sector we as the European
Union have an essential role to play we
are aware aware of that with investment
with regulations and with incentives but
it's Europe's business that must lead
the transition and the only way to find
solutions that work for all is to create
them together a new business way for
Europe has to be partially made in
Brussels without any question but it
cannot totally be made in Brussels our
future will be co-designed and our
future will be co-created with you it is
when we managed to join forces that we
see Europe at its best this is the
essence of our social market economy it
has always been the essence of our
social market economy and I'm convinced
it will always be the essence of our
social market economy the European Way
private investment and common good this
is the European Way innovation and
responsibility this is the European Way
competitiveness and sustainability this
is the European Way and this is the new
industrial way for Europe we are
thinking of and I can't wait to get to
work towards this with leaders like you
and in this best sense
long live Europe thank you so much
thank you very much indeed Madam
President your answer your answer to the
question do we want to be a global
player or the playground very clear